lead us to victory lead us to victory
new colony on Mars
Lili also wants Tony to put his hand on
her head yeah I want to feel small for
one I know there was a troublemaker it
happens to me a postive nation we're
heading to the airport right now we're
gonna go to LA
what's up believe nation we just got
back from Disney three days ago
and we decided hey let's go on another
trip we are off to LA I'm I'm bringing
Nina in three of my people from China
dine salsa we are going to the 20
Robin's events there
unleash the power within unleash the
power within Nina's got a lot of power
so neither of us have been to 420 rebels
event no and I'm excited I'm scared
Nina scared scared it's good it's good
to be scared we're going to see what we
can do with the video your honor to
bring any videos in Sweden will be
filming inside but documents some of the
trip and meet some of the people were
going with they will have some times
we're going to start by meeting up with
Mike and Lily who are right here we're
taking Lily with us we're taking Italy
we're leaving Mike well we're taking
Lily with us ha ha ha
Nina is a small person Marc I'm a small
person too here we go
time to travel this is Lily what do you
do Lily no I feel awful thing lots of
things yeah I'm the extreme learner so
Lily does a lot of different classes of
TBS salsa Zumba what really heal you oh
the IOC yes well not development
workshops and she's doing our first year
one word workshop coming up in April
although this might be oh yeah it might
have already passed I don't know anyway
she's doing the first year one before
shop so excited I'm excited
Nina is way ahead of us we gotta catch
up you're cold
ok we're going we're going to LA don't
worry running complete we're going to LA
you know I got through Lily got the X on
her random pictures of she's still in
Lyons and getting the detailed questions
and as we were coming through security
via the security guard said remember
take control of your life but yeah I
like that goodness I feel like we should
always get inspirational messages from
airport security
good job u.s. airport security we found
her I'm nervous I know there was a
troublemaker
it's Wiggy you took too long answer the
questions on the screen Lily's like
reading each question do I have firearms
let me think about it
make sure you can go to all go comfort
we're hungry so we're going to get some
stretchers
Nina's trying to catch some Pokemon
Leena
how's the Pokemon we know you're looking
at Pokemon we know it we know you're
looking at Pokemon Assoc with Nina
anywhere she goes somewhere new she's
looking for Pokemon what's at the
airport Nina nothing so sighs what are
we doing is what's happening here who
was saying hi to Oh son
I missed it I missed my moment and again
you have one opportunity a second story
a nice and very sad very sad are we
doing Nina hmm my cameo Lilly's pants
are falling down
oh it's not that kind of Chandler Lily
it's not that kind of channel lovely
family-friendly content here okay we're
here a little bit early actually a lot
of it early that's okay we're going to
film some impress those for you guys
yeah
Hey look who showed up
oh it's Alex and Edwin they're joining
us on our trip as well yeah thank you
for inviting it
it wasn't smooth entrance so far I
didn't have any weird pat-down ah I know
they didn't take me for that it's a room
area
you know though I hear you checked
random check I had a lot of those in my
life actually literally got random check
go there you know really rigidly going
on there I think she took too long to
answer Debbie she took too long to
answer the question of are you bringing
firearms into the country just like
thinking about it so the response time
was so slow okay so we got a real
printed I got my receipt I don't know I
mean yeah you joined Lily
but you know I'm solidarity she's like
you want to join him on look yes I am in
the left side oh that's good Nina and I
left Lily we told Lily we're going to
pretend like we don't know you
Wow so everybody's hungry Alex and Edwin
haven't eaten yet so the men are going
to go hunt for food we're gonna get some
mass wall burgers I'll why do you want
to go to Wahlburgers well actually it's
funny about a year ago or two years ago
I was watching a wall bar move in and I
watched the documentary and he's talking
about the burger place and I started her
for his family anything a reality show
no I haven't um oh yeah yeah yeah
haven't they seen anyway so you want it
open oh yeah I did I did they have one
at the Toronto Airport guys best city in
the world but big city not Toronto
Airport great city in the room
Toronto's vested in the world yeah it's
pretty Troma believe what's happening
Alex I'm smelling the beach and I am eat
it I went to eat I did
thank you kindly I don't think thank you
Nima said she wanted the bacon burger
and they had two options one had
jalapeno peppers on it and if you feel
she's enjoy that so I just got hurt the
other one that was a bacon burger and
only realized afterwards that it's a
half a pound of beef apparently a lot
and we also ordered other dinner and she
also wanted side fries so we'll see how
Nina does it was Alex's idea
hey okay we can't throw Alex under the
bus like that although we did talk about
on the way in maybe one night we should
go by the way I actually my room my area
maybe my hand or my foot randomly goes
up when I speak so just a heads up you
see one of my hands in the middle night
just like being raised above my head
don't freak out I think we definitely
legitimately and if you actually get
that account it's pretty awesome
alright I mean said I could lend I catch
does my condoms oh this has infrared
yeah yeah this is this is nice it's nice
okay okay we've got to try to find a lie
just infrared tell me because I don't
want to go all possible
you know other than I did you like
blankets dude yeah but you move around
whatever like especially because my arms
around right there are people there are
some things that you can't unsee alright
let's go find the girls all right Nina
so we got you the jr. burger
so enjoy underestimate my hunger
pipeline okay well I got fries if you
want to live now thank you sir open it
I'll remember that's mine you got the
other one Jase don't eat mine went yummy
I just want to see it - yeah that's the
our burger that's the best one
okay they're your junior burger you
wanted bacon
Nina's open her Junior burger it's
actually half a pound of meat name it's
the opposite of a junior prisoner it's
the biggest rigor they have see you
I did not underestimate your appetite
how is it yummy that's okay good time to
eat hell we're going to show you how
Lily keeps her ketchup gonna find out I
have a lot of chicken we open the
ketchup hack and then dips to catch up
in no mess as use your creativity guys
like how what's the alternative way to
eating of anything it will make a mess
and spilling it all over the place and
and then divide them and then different
food such as different to Alex very
intrigued I was a poutine you should try
it how about stop by it is not so great
though harmony nice island she's gonna
say oh yeah
I hear what you're saying this
difference will change paint taste
little furnace exactly we're all going
to the Tony Robbins conference for two
reasons one is hopefully to improve
ourselves to learn the reason why I
picked these guys what was they were the
first one at TBS to embrace their one
word and find it so Mena is what you
want more huh Lilly is extraordinary
Edwin is Alex's the law so I wanted to
reward them and take them to go see Tony
and hopefully we can share insights to
help all of us become better versions of
ourselves also were teachers and I
wanted to learn from Tony you know we
teach three hours at night three
different classes Tony's on stage for
like 8 10 12 hours at a time and I was
hoping that maybe we could learn
something from him that we could bring
to our classes as well to be better
injectors so we'll see I'm excited to
learn for him so we're going to go
around the room and find out one thing
that everybody is hoping to learn from
the study in LA I don't know if that
means we're thinking maybe I'm always
there things I always want to do and I
was just think about it and I'll do it
so thinking them I should just go for
action-adventure lon gravitate not use
it right away
thank you for taking a tee in Eric's
room there's actually several things I
want to work on but the most important
thing is that I feel like my outside
does not reflect my inside
like inside I feel like a beast in the
outside I'm more like a goat maybe right
yeah like I like it small enough so I
really really feel like I just not to
manifest what's inside of me something's
holding me back authentic mode I don't
know what it is I find out I liked it I
think I wonder what happened to the
reason why it took my one word and be
able to have them reflect it off every
day a lot of like really tapping the
thesis I want to be able to you
happiness demand cheering 24/7 I love it
yes so what's the one thing that I want
to work on I wanna work on being a
better leader for everyone a better
example I think I'm holding myself back
I'm holding myself back because a lot of
limiting beliefs procrastination a bunch
of things and it frustrates me because I
can be playing at a higher level and I'm
not I'm hoping to find some answers
about myself
yeah boom for me I'm most excited for
the experience I surround myself with
this kind of content daily and there is
nobody else that I would really want to
go and meet there's nobody I want to
meet like one-on-one and pick their
brain but I'm excited to go and just be
a part of the experience and I'm not
necessarily looking for any one thing
I'm open I'm open to being surprised and
I just I want to feel it I want to see
how Tony does it and I want to see what
goes here
so yeah
and I want my hair rub now I can
accomplish Lilly also wants Tony to put
his hand on her head yeah I want to
smell small for one necessarily amigo at
the same time physically I want to visit
a toy but they're just gonna let me look
this time before I got the ILC 15 is in
the middle everyone's got the window
he's excited on the other side of the
aircraft the other side okay Alex five
hours six hours
oh I'm glad I'm on this side of the
airplane I'm glad I'm on this earlier we
met a fan of the channel Mike on the
plane I am sorry nobody check out
Michael Duggal just coming to the Tony
Robinson thank you yeah
and what's your favorite video on the
channel as we met again
all of them are raised around agreements
functioning to be very engaged ability
[ __ ]
a job at the airport filling you with a
jumbo collectively
because subscribe and watch them they
after they went up whether it's a rarity
you know I thank you for the video
although are you have an hour and we are
conditionally Michael do go ladies and
gentlemen go check him out
[Music]
we had this fun game where we had to
connect Scarlett Johansson's a Brad Pitt
and we finally figured it out my career
with movie trivia and I get very
competitive things so she figured it out
as a team effort
Lilly really helped us yeah I believe we
came out with a putter
what was the finer game Oh 60 views of
entrepreneurs that was a pretty good
game we enjoyed iron
welcome to LA everyone we're going to
find an uber and head to our Airbnb
all right our uber is here whoo
okay without even go forth Alec Romulus
leader lead us to victory lead us to
victory new colony on Mars
Alex saya and everyone all right it's
just past three in the morning for us
midnight here in LA we are going to get
some sleep settle into our place I don't
think I'll be able to film I'm bring the
camera tomorrow
skipping recording devices in so people
do an intro into some pictures for you
guys looking for the ends of shut-eye
and getting up early to go register for
Tony Robbins and hopefully have some
coffee with my sister who's also coming
for the event I'm excited we'll see you
soon